حكايتها ليست من وحي الخيال
انها واقعنا
الولد اللي في بطني انك فانت عم تؤذيني
انا وعم تؤذيني له يعني كان طريقه الضرب
مش طبيعيه
فانا رحت على بيت اهلي اساسا كنت مقرره
متوصل معه مدبيه ما يكون في حاجه بيني
وبينها تربطني به نهائيا
حتى اهلي وقفه معي صراحه بس بعدين لان انا
اللي في بطني
فرصه ثانيه وهي كانت غلط
على القران
حتى اليوم ليس هناك من قانون يحمي النساء
من العنف الاسري في ليبيا والعديد من
الدول العربيه رغم جهود النسويه المستمره
لنشطات الليبيات في سبيل مكافحه هذا
العنفي وتجري معه
مشاكل من اهل الجنه
عن طريق التطبيقات او عن طريق رسائل
التليفون
انا انسانه مش كويسه
اقامت علاقات شرعيه مع رجال اخرين وحاولوا
تهجموا علي اكثر من مره في البيت بس انا
طبعا عندي غرفه خاصه بيا كل شيء مسكر في
الباب عليا انا ولدي وبعد ان قررت
الانفصال عنه واستقرت في بيت منفصل هي
وابنها اتزوجها اليها متوسنا زعما ان لا
ماوى والديه في يوم من الايام كان شهر
تسعه 2020 جاني قال لي انا جيت في الليل
وما عنديش مكان نقعد فيه لو سمحتي
انا الشقه فيها ثلاثه غرف
[موسيقى]
ابني ورحت على غرفه ثانيه
في الليل او ثلاثه مش متفكره بالضبط انا
طبعا
قوه وجاب حاجه منعرفش ان هي مثل قطعه
القماش حاول تحطها لي فمي فانا استنتجات
الشخصيه انه هو طبعا كان يبكي ياخدني
يرفعني للمدينه طرابلس لانه طرابلس مس ما
فيش قانون كافي فيقدر يعمل في الشيء الي
هو بده اياه طبعا
الشجار بيننا وفي هذيك الفتره لما تعارفنا
في في الليله هذيك همم اضربني همم خشمي
اصبح ينصف ويدي انكسرت وعندي هالبرد ردود
وجسمي اصبح اخضر طبعا
لو سمحت خلاص في صباح اليوم التالي لهذه
الحادثه اتصل بها زوجها يريد رؤيه ابنه
الامر الذي اثار شكوكاها باحتمال ان يذهب
به خارج المدينه
وهذا ما حدث بالفعل فلم تجد من حل امامها
سوى ان تتقدم بشكوى ضده ليتم القاء القبض
عليه بتهمه ايذاء احد افراد الاسره ولا
يتم الافراج عنه الا بتنازلها عن حققه
وما نعرفش شو صار معه طبعا لما كبرت
القضيه واصبحت قضيه راي عام وانتشر الصور
في كل مكان يعني لو انا في الهدى فيه في
في مجموعه من الناس جابوه لمدينه اسواره
وسالموني اشخاص نعرفهم وقالوا احنا لقيناه
في الشارع طبعا حاله ابني لما رجعوه لي
وعندها تقرير طبي مضروب بجسمها في كدمات
كثيره ابني همم
احمر يعني عندي تقرير طبي في الموضوع
وهربت لكن ماذا عن بقيه النساء في ليبيا
مش بلد امن ليبيا مكان مش ولد املي انا
باي طريقه لو ان انا كنت قاعده في ليبيا
ممكن يكون قاعد عندي بمخاوف يعني نكون
قاعده بفكر في المستقبل بس انا جيت لي
بلاد امنه وفرت الامان ووفره للرعايه
ووفرت لي مستقبلي ولدي يعني ولدي يدرس
عندهم وطمنيتني قالوا لي لو اي حاجه تصير
لك هم هيكون اول المتهمين
حكايتك حكايهتها
حكايتنا كلنا
لنرويها ونسمعها لعلنا ننهي العنف ضدها في
يوم قريب